a new study claims some popular oak
based breakfast foods marketed to
children have dangerous levels of a
chemical some health officials linked to
cancer
the nonprofit Environmental Working
Group says 26 samples from Quaker and
General Mills products contained unsafe
levels of the weed killer glyphosate in
August we reported on their first study
it found 31 samples of other oat based
products including some organic
contained the chemical in order is here
with some of the new findings and good
morning good morning Nora glyphosate is
an herbicide used on farms across the
u.s. the powerful chemical kills weeds
but it's controversial because it's been
classified by the World Health
Organization as probably carcinogenic to
humans once again this environmental
group is warning that many of the
breakfast foods you enjoy could be bad
for you there's really no reason
consumers should have to worry about
whether they're getting a dose of
glyphosate with their breakfast every
morning
that was the Environmental Working Group
Scott Faber in August talking about a
study his group commissioned that found
the weed killer glyphosate in dozens of
breakfast products we're very concerned
that consumers are eating more
glyphosate than they know now a second
round of testing shows 28 more samples
analyzed contain glyphosate residues ten
samples from General Mills Cheerios
products and 18 samples from Quaker
brand products ranging from instant
oatmeal to snack bars 26 of the samples
came back with residue levels higher
than what the group believes is safe for
children General Mills says trace
amounts of pesticides are found in the
majority of food we all eat and the
company follows the very strict rules
set by the FDA and EPA who determined
the safe levels for food products Quaker
told us that any minimal levels of
glyphosate that may remain in finished
products are significantly below
regulatory limits and well within
compliance of the safety standards but
the World Health Organization says
glyphosate is a probable carcinogen in
humans and the state of California lists
it as a chemical known to the state to
cause cancer I find the results of this
report concerning dr. Philip Landrigan a
pediatrician and one of the world's
experts on children's environmental
health advice
as parents to move away from brands
containing glyphosate and buy organic
products for their children that do not
contain the chemical children are
exquisitely vulnerable to toxic
chemicals such as glyphosate even a tiny
dose it would probably be harmless to an
adult carries much greater risk for a
child
Oh Monsanto which sells products
containing glyphosate says the study is
misleading
it says the chemical is safe and it
maintains it does not cause cancer
Monsanto also says that adults would
have to eat huge quantities of these
foods every day to exceed the EPA's
limit for glyphosate exposure General
Mills says food safety is a top priority
and Quaker stands by its products so I'm
sitting at home watching you this
morning what should I do I'm worried
about honey nut cheerios so if you
listen to dr. Landrigan who was
specializes in children's environmental
health and has for a long time he would
tell you that children are very
sensitive to small amounts of chemicals
they take in more food per pound of body
weight than adults do and so that that
exposes them higher and they're more
sensitive and he really believes that
parents should look out for the kids in
terms of trying to make sure that they
do not ingest chemicals as much as
possible
he says try to move toward organic the
Quaker says it's safe so Quaker and
gentle mills are saying look there's a
lot of this in our foods and especially
if you're an adult you know Monsanto
says if you're an adult you'd have to
eat ridiculous amounts of these foods to
expose yourself but there is it and so
there is that debate but I think people
who specialize in children are saying
that they are concerned about this
especially for kids and their parents
right kids yeah I think it's good
information for people to know thank you
Anna